ja es geht nicht wichtiger im Le als
Geschenk das falsche Geschenk kann
langjährige bezieh für immer kaputt
machen und richtige kann sie für immer
[Musik]
retten he g die ultimative
philosophische Geschenktipps und redet
drüber dass im Akt vom schenke also
utopisches Potenzial schlummert aber mal
Barbara die schön Geschenk reden die DF
wir am Schluss von derfolg aufm B sehr
gespannt sponsort vom Produktionsteam
schön oder vollfreud ist die schönste
Freud vor Gag ganze Bezi kaputt
machen g g dir mit Bezi machen nein also
mus andere Frage ja
[Musik]
was ich ganz schlimm g also ich kann
mich nicht erinner verdt ich von me
Großvater hab ich immer ein schocky
bekommen mit Z drauf und zwar immer die
Bank geh ganz
neuf ja aber es ist dar schlecht immer
das schönste Geschenk für ganz
le ich fin leensphasef ich fin mag ich
mich extrem gut erinner ich habe immer
Barbies gewünscht und ich habe keine
über gefunden das ist irgendwie ganz
schlechtcht das S
ich jetzt s ich dir
ich in großer Liebe großes barbus baut
und ob schildppt hier fehlen nur noch
die Barbies und sich mE Gotte erbarmt
und ich habe sehr g verhnis zu me Gotte
und
Barb
meh und ich
odery nein interessant ich schönste
Geschenk wür ich sagen das
kindheitsgeschenk und zwar
Spielkonsole
so so gewünscht und hab Nintendo 64
bekommen das
grö
aber ich fin sch wen
sberemachte g schön und das ist schönen
wenn Kind ich ma mega gern aber ichon so
viel schö
Geschenke aber Kind machen so lustige
geschen ja das dankerst und dann ist
aber
eigentlich
drin ein yogaatar das ich
immer s Yoga nicht das mit YOG so kann
ich da Yoga machen auf schritis
Avatar und kann ich
schaffen macht Yoga tip to so Sachen
sind aber mach die FIN nicht gut machst
du kein Geschenk selber ja also ich
mache jetzt Geschenk viele mit der Kind
den für die ganz Verwandtschaft insofern
Hilfe mit die Tochter vi und hat das
noch nicht so gut da muss man im noch
aber ich selber für irgend anders selber
machen nein B ich ganz unfähig nein aber
was was ist du gut g Z wenn im Vorfeld
informiert so statistike Herr Schwizer
Frau schwizerin geht 340 frankenus für
wnachsgeschenk im Durchschnitt
und ganz vorne ganz vorne g und
geldch Süßigkeit spielsach und Bücher
ich find das triff bei mir recht gut
interessant ist was find unangenehm
unenehm find ich
geschenkzieh also du bist jetzt nicht so
fit und Abo für der fitnesscub ja gut
oder du KST Frau z. du jetzt nicht so
wirklich toll Kochkurs ja
das für W gchenk z.B reizw für W ist die
reizw
neinalfall beide W sag oder mussp
Geschenke ist nicht so klar wer da wer
beschenkt oder klar und V allem ist Form
V erzieh so
bestechvuch ich gebe damit du gibst so
das ist natürlich gchenk drin ganz TIF
so sag der Charakter dass du noch bis
Schul und wieder musst
zurückge ja es ist super interessant ich
finde natürlich im schenke ist immer
wichtig wie es verpackt da gebe ich mir
extrem viel Mühe ich finde die halbe mir
die ist verpackig ja wie ich das schön
ich find schön wennack
also ja ist doch schön gemacht da schöne
ruseli ringsum luck ganz ganze armade
chuseli den H da
gich Farb
du was ne aber ich find wirklich g
schönpack ist doch
sch eigentlich ist das mal der Schutz g
im im Bürgertum 18 jahhund damit der
Wettbewerb mit strank kommt damit nicht
die andere Gott das G ich muss mir
schenen und soer noch eine Fall mit dem
Wettbewerb dem gabch oder machus der
französische soziolog wo man sich gtigch
oder und das Geschenk muss verpackt sie
damit so die anderen n aber in der Regel
macht vor all andere ja schenke ist also
alles andere als einfach es ist wahre
Kunst oder auf R Ries Stress
wach Langar geschenkt einfach der Konsum
Überfluss Gesellschaft irgendwie das
hteremt
sch so
verloren nein ich ich weiß es git so
dieo sag sch und findet wahsinnig hhaf
ich hab mit dem gar nicht D ganz ehrlich
will ich immer so danke wenn Argument
Überflussgesellschaft ist nein wenn es
Argument ist Überflussgesellschaft dann
kanst du ganz viel andere Sachen
schenken du h PZ schenen wo kan Garten
setz du sch du g sch
zin g
zum oder du kanst z.B zum tröler ins
Brock und Al herster Sache
vü ich glaube der Punkt ist die SAG sch
n die hab zwei Problem W lös erstens
genau das du sag Stress das kann man
umgekehrt sagen sie w sich nicht
investieren sich die nicht zum such oder
was sie so sagen ist ich so viel
züch mir doch
lieberelber e unökonomisch schenke und
das find die beides so trurig beides ist
doch trurig ja ich weiß es nicht also
zweite Punkt ist zumindest sehr
interessant weil das stimmt ja wirklich
es gibt Ökonom sch Waldvogel
heißt Schank wir nachind org V der
wertvernichtig also sind sch vi so viel
Geschenke wo verschenchenkt wo einfach
nicht Pass die andere findet so halbgut
Bruch Zweck was und wenn du dir selber
kaufen da wär viel besser investiert
genau DER Klassiker die Frau got Diren
Pulli schanken dirfallt WFB no pas genau
den
bist passt viel besser als die Sache ich
du würd dir da selber kaufen und sieft
sich dafür Reg war ke fertig ist doch
total trurig das doch trurig im ges ist
Risiko dass nicht passt D es nicht
perfekt gefallt ich finde irgendwie P
schlecht
will formis dir Gedanken machen zenüber
dir überlegen was Kön dem gefallen dir
irg aus das was untern
aber ich interessant finde jetzt
W feministische Gedanke hinter mus mal
ach wie viel Frauen
schen auf der Geburtstag wie nach wie
viel Frauen ganzessier Geschenk
m überle alle und und find das Geschen
und so aber es ist doch für alle
eigentlich schön wenn es den letlich G
natürlich ist es be Einzel viel viel die
das ist mir viel aber grundsätzlich
feststell überleid das schön ja aber ich
fin J ma du
spontanasing das
wochenand schla was
zu viel dem jetzteden nicht nur über
wach nur über
grundsätzlich sag sch an sich geht
auf sch sie
wüns mit bringen kann man alles machen
aber dann verlagheitsituation was nicht
bringt bring eigentlich find ich schön
ich sch einfach ich find total schön
Moment ze was ich mir über das ist
irendwi bewundwer ja ich fin das schön
der Michael s Philosoph was man für Geld
nicht kaufen kann got dem ganze Schank
no und seit W eigentlich wieeder her
Waldvogel das seit nur no quasi der
duschwertwand also so sag du h mir für
25 Fr 25 fr aber natürlich
umuschgarantie inkludiert damit dir
sicherfallt man riskiert sich das führt
dazu dass so wunschl machen den
stendwie
silberdose frlich
beimoli
Teddy fr 50hältlich be und so wier und
das ist den wirk nur no ABH du genau der
Artikel du weißür das genüberfallt aber
es unterlauft natür die IDE vom schen
auch nlich dass du dir überle dass du
dich riskier und im Geschenk versuchst
be
Sinn vom schen das ist bezieh stärkt das
ist Art V Kommunikation und
Kommunikation gibt immer die vier Ebene
es gibt Sachebene was sage ich aber ich
drü ich ge kund über mich selber oder
aber es ist App zB oder also oder jetzt
das Buch
oder asupser oder wie Kollege der W es
Geschenk W ich selber noch neu entdecke
also ist Art von Kommunikation das würde
ich auf jeden Fall und VI zurü oder zum
Maus zu dem soziolog wo als als vorlag
sozusag vom schanken oder V der
Diskussion vom Schank der sogenannte
Bruch von potlat nimmt wo be Native
Americans Rolle gespielt h wo es
wirklich so fast schanken a aggressive
Akt praktiziert worden schkt muss gich
züken zum ze
viel W und sch
das und du B
Schauf ger best wer wenn ich überkme
muss ich sofort
repziieren aber das find ich so typisch
für
halt der Schuld sch vi aber einfach mal
über
schön
genauak
gen
geht Verfall des schenken ganz schön
minim Moral oder und die idiotische Idee
V Geschenkartikel das H so aufggt das
Produkt V nur erfunden wird damit mus
verchenke und der ne Geld zurückgarantie
das find des Teufels oder genau das
WAG und auch
stimmtkartikel Abteil
geschenkkel unpersönlich oder Mass war
was natürlich aufret und
anderen ist d es genau die Logik vom TCH
die kapitalistische Logik V V
konsequenzbricht oder
nach einfach pure schenke ich sch dir
ein ich w nicht zurü s einfach e ir dasf
aber der Maus der mach W der SE gilgar
die ganze Zivilisation also überhaupt
Idee von
Pflicht me also wenn ich das Gefühl oh
me Gott ich sch ich muss dir drü und
gchen magische Kraft
einersit ich muss dir zü und andere ist
da steckt Teil von dir drin wenn gchen
von dir ist ist
wie
YOG
persönlichstelle bist du immer das ist
schön
aberlichicht also ist klar sch ist vor
allem Kommunikation Art V Risiko und es
Bindemittel Bezi zum
schussevor über sich selber sch es git
wihelm Schmid der große philosop
Philosoph vom schenken und beschenkt
werden und se se ab und zu sich selber
Geschenk
machen ich fin das nicht per
Definition wirklich drum dass du
versuchst sch finden was W m gegenüber
wie kann ich bezieh stär das geht dochch
mit sich selber aber ich muss nicht rät
drüber was ich wett wirklich
nein aber aber was was heißt das ich kan
das für mich schon sag me du nicht mir
selber gut Z selber Geschenk ne nein
sich g du das Ken das Mus mal gut klapp
Computer zu und
badwan g doch nicht das Bad schen nein
kom jetzt ja aber du schst zit mit dir
selber machst den du dir geschenkiste
für dich
[Gelächter]
selber oder
also mit mit mit Frau aber
ich mich selber machen z.B Geschenk ich
selber Gefül nein das ist überstretche
vom Begriff V schen genau ich w ich und
ich w aber no wen ob du dir
wünsch nein ich bin wirklich also nicht
konkret eigentlich du schon S drin wer
weiß bist du ein Rieser oder ein
Schnieder B sogenannte Ries
R also es ist schadeack e aber ich
nein unfassbar wie du das
machst ich w mir nie
m
ich
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
g jetzt musst du mit
mir
ich ich natürlich den nche ich
hab ich wirkich wunderbar sag der sagte
hey danke viel mal großartigen
Team
oder so schön das ist sogar wertvoll
fantastisch Bü
wir ol das warum g
gchen originell ist
originell was ich
ma J
[Gelächter]
so zum Thema sch was bedeutet g sch
Kommentar und Z gespr mit Michael
Sandell und andere zum Thema
Freundschaft mit in Schmidt